welcome to the DS show we're taking a
break now and we're gonna talk about
some nutrition so important you work
your mind your heart your soul but let
the body you take care of it it's a
blessing from the Creator but now you're
taking a break and maybe you go and get
some Krispy Kreme Dunkin Donuts and oh
who's this so we got someone in the
background
chief nutritionist was for seven years
with dr. Mercola it's almost studying
nutrition for 40 years what you said
that's a problem here talk to us well
what you were mentioning there Eddie was
fake food and it reminds me of a
nutrition counseling I did with the
five-year-old son of a dear friend of
mine who lives down in the Houston area
and I went shopping with her one day and
her five-year-old son Jaffa came along
and Jaffer had an ax at a tendency to
want to eat as much sugar as he could
and
the the adult world around him other
than his mother was unfortunately all
too supportive of supplying him with the
sugar because they said they thought
that you know they were being nice to a
child but unfortunately the adult world
has a very unhealthy tendency to project
their own food addictions their own food
preferences onto children and in the
process corrupt a child's taste buds and
turn children into sugar addicts to some
extent and this had happened to Java and
he was he was always looking to eat as
sugar when it was around but I was
thinking I wanted to help my my friend I
wanted to help her teach her son and
sugar
and fake foods in general
we're not good for for his for his body
for his health but you know how do I get
through to a five year old well while I
was shopping with with Java and his
mother John first started taking items
off the shelf and he would show them to
me and the first several items he took
off shelves were refined and processed
food and and it just I I was inspired to
relate to Java in this way he would take
something off the shelf and he showed to
me he said Jim what about this is this
good and I say I would do this I would
say he ain't fake food chopper fake food
warning warning fake food and he started
laughing and then he he did it again
with another refinement process junk
food item and I did the same thing you
guys look got a little game going on
here now that's right that's right and
we did that about six or seven times
each time he would show me some fake
food I'd say fake food chopper warning
warning and do not eat and he laughed
and and he really enjoyed that but then
he showed me some real food
he actually the first real food he
showed me was a whole coconut
and I said ryofu chopper
ding-ding-ding-ding ding-ding-ding-ding
real food
and he enjoyed that and I didn't think
that much of it I thought it was it was
entertaining for Java and in the moment
and I was I was doing my best to connect
with him and then I was speaking to his
mother a couple weeks after that and his
mother told me that since that
since that time where I went shopping
and I I did the ain't ain't to say fake
food and the ding-ding-ding leading to
her for real food
ja fer was not eating any sugar in fact
that that that evening that I talked to
his mother he was there with her in the
kitchen and I said I'd like to say hello
to Jaffa and
and so sure is his mother samal up but
put the phone up to to Java and and he
said Jim guess what I'm eating I said
what are you eating
he said I'm eating duck he was eating
doctor he's eating freshly cooked duck
and I said
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding meaning real
food let's go ahead really really
because some people get confused like we
talk about sugar they think okay this is
something natural that the Creator has
given us when we talk about sugar retal
my white process we're fine I mean this
is just fake food I mean this is odd
what please define so it give us a
better understanding and then also the
addictive element of it and the harm
that it actually causes yeah
well as I've said before sugar has no
nutritional value for the body it's it
has a drug like effect on the body it's
not having a nourishing effect and about
yes there's some calories to burn
there's no there's no nutrients to
support the body's ability to metabolize
those calories for energy sugar creates
metabolic turmoil in the body it's just
a matter of how much of that type of of
stress your body can handle but sugar
will will interfere with the body's
ability to maintain
what in medicine is called homeostasis
homeostasis is basically a medical term
referring to the body's ability to
maintain a relative balance in our
biochemistry in our physiology or the
body's ability to return to a relative
balance in our biochemistry and
physiology
the more refinement process sugar people
eat
the more they actually make it difficult
for their body to maintain a relative
balance and ultimately sugar can hurt a
person's energy it can put them on a
mood roller coaster where you may feel
up for a little while after eating sugar
but
the faster and higher your blood sugar
levels go up the lower your blood sugar
levels will come down
and this is why people who eat they
typically experience what is known as a
mood rollercoaster
it's not just bad for your energy bad
for your moods there's there's quite a
bit of research implicating sugar as a
causative factor in heart disease and
cancer and basically all degenerative
illnesses including of course cavities
one of my heroes was a dentist by the
name of dr. Weston Price who deserves to
be considered the most accomplished
nutrition and health researcher and the
first half of the 20th century and he
identified that the very first symptom
of physical degeneration and people who
are not getting their nutrition right
and eating too much what I call fake
food refined and processed junk food
fast food convenience food very for a
symptom they they often had was tooth
decay
that's a great advice we're eat real
food we're gonna cut out now look at
what you're gonna put in your body and
ask yourself how is this benefiting me
and if you're putting things in your
bodies are actually not even benefiting
you but they're actually harming you
you're putting things in your body the
body that the Creator has given you
you're not honoring it you're actually
dishonouring it and instead of putting
in things that now are nutritious and if
you want like some sweet let's give them
we got we got some some alternatives you
got bananas you got what what dates you
got oranges right these are the things
that we can substitute real food real
food is basic if you want something
sweet yeah look to look to the natural
sweetness that's found
in nature and the way of
fruits that you just mentioned and many
other sweet fruits and also vegetables
such as carrot beet and also
vegetables of the of the squash family
especially
winter squash summer squash but it's
very important to understand that what
people enjoy as a matter of taste is
largely
because of it has to do with what
they're familiar with what
it has to do with with
the habits that they have
the good news is you can re-educate your
taste buds and learn to enjoy real
health building health supporting food
and get to a point where
the the fake food that once did taste
good to you no longer taste good too
so beautiful advice you want to avoid
those mood swings you want to prevent
cancer diabetes obesity don't hook your
kids up or even yourself on this fake
food give a real food hope you enjoyed
the message we'll see you next time
subscribe if you haven't already peace